yeah so they put this guy they put
these guys out on this island called
grizzly island out in british columbia
well grizzlies everywhere
everywhere it's nice out there though
yeah now as the fish start drying up
they get desperate it's [ __ ]
dangerous so not only do they have like
horns but they have
huge boom sounds that i think there's
somebody
there to scare the bears you can't you
know
bring up grizzly island brian grizzly
mountain yeah uh is it island or
mountain uh it's i think it's island
dude get rid of alone
just type in uh
there it is
don't don't tell me who wins because i
i'm in the middle of it still oh oh i'll
tell you who wins white guy white guy
all white guys
white guys white girls now here's the
thing here's what's interesting about it
um
i'm not looking because you're it's not
no this is just the actual island i
don't know there's a grizzy island my
favorite is every time they have they
have like some people there a lot of
times they're women who are really great
at survival but here's the problem
they're really good at gathering they
gather mushrooms they gather berries
they gather
roots
and they don't bring a bow and arrow
they don't bring a fishing rod and a you
gonna starve
you gotta kill animals you gotta kill
[ __ ] animals there's one dude there
was this one dude he had a belly he had
a heart condition i'm like this guy is a
[ __ ] he's so dumb and he he didn't
bring any weapons he tried to kill
grouse they have these like forest hens
you know what his plan was to kill a
grouse to throw a stone at him this
[ __ ] idiot he didn't laugh he threw a
stone and he goes ah damn it now i'm
having chest pins i don't want to die
six days come get me i'm like get that
you're a [ __ ]
some people yeah alone it's not the most
entertaining show i think like compared
to naked and afraid i'm making afraid i
feel like put a little more production
in it it's a little suspect like that
beer grills whatever like there was that
other show the lo the the survivor guy
survivor yeah if you do it real and you
don't do like overproduction like add
[ __ ] to it or like stumble upon a cobra
or whatever if it's like real and you're
just shooting yes
pretty boring yes like alone like really
nothing happens no nothing happens like
the chance of getting attacked by
something's not good that's correct ever
that's correct it's very rare dude very
rare very very very rare
by the way try to catch try to kill a
deer with a bow and arrow yeah try to do
that try to get close enough switching
unless that's your thing yeah if you're
just shooting on the weekends to kill
time chance of you killing a live
[ __ ] deer in the real forest daddy
good luck no you gotta know animal
behavior you gotta know what the tracks
are this guy who did it on alone he'd
been doing it his whole life i'll tell
you i don't know what season they're on
on netflix but there's a guy who kills a
moose dude that's a big deal yeah with a
bow and arrow no he jumped on his back
knife throat
that's how i was blood
just kidding that didn't happen i don't
know i don't know how he killed him but
i know some guy killed a [ __ ] moose
on there i'm just i'm a little if you've
seen him like oh well
good for you he wins yeah also you
realize
nature hates your guts
nature nature don't give a [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ] no she was like
whatever dude you're gonna you're not
catching anything oh you feel bad for
yourself dude there's a [ __ ]
ram that ran into the [ __ ] barbed
wire fence over there he's been stuck
there yeah and then wolves ate him ass
first yeah and his head's still in the
[ __ ] fence
welcome to nature nature is a
[ __ ] oh and yesterday on [ __ ]
uh happy hour friday that grizzly bear
we watch eat his own [ __ ] cubs you so
hungry
nature also nature is not about
grizzlies also the [ __ ] in nature that's
invisible like amoebas and different
viruses and parasites that [ __ ] you how
about that one pair of scissors imagine
that one parasite if you're swimming i
guess it's in fresh water it gets to
your brain just oh you died it's color
it's an amoeba it's an amiibo that gets
in your brain you die it's very random
but it's like you know if it's like
still water whatever you jump in the
pool or whatever and it goes to your
brain yeah you go see the doctor like
we're so sorry yeah like yo but you're
so sorry yeah but we're so sorry i'm so
sorry what'd you say she's like
permanently blinded it went one of them
a form of that
it uh ate away at her eye and they
caught it quickly enough i guess it was
like under a contact but it was a
serious serious issue she wants all
sorts of doctors she's she's lucky who
was this it's my cousin yeah you know it
was at a pool it was your actual cousin
yeah holy [ __ ] you know someone that got
that weird amoeba and i don't know if
it's the same one but it's one that it
eats away at your eye and she has
permanent damage to her that's why you
don't swim in like in in swamps
in ponds that are not moving there's so
much it's called pam pam is extremely
rare since 1962 only 154 known cases wow
i mean your chances are pretty good but
you can get giardia real quick you can
get these weird things do you you know
what daddy likes to do in nature you
know daddy likes to do i'm hiking if i
see you especially when i was in
colorado if i'm hiking on the road or
whatever i see a stream running likes to
put his
mouth down there little nature's here's
the nature's waterfall here's why i
don't know nothing about that i don't
know if it's running water right i've
seen enough negan afraid right so if
it's running you're good if it's
stagnant water if it's stagnant daddy's
in trouble sometimes though the running
water is coming from an area that has
livestock and when the livestock is
[ __ ] in that or near it you're going
to get yourself all kinds of [ __ ] in
there and you're going to get listeria
you know i just feel good
now i won't do it in foreign land yeah
but in america that fresh american
mountain hitters yeah i just put my
mouth right there
never got sick